tobin you've worked on nearly 100 film
productions probably more than that and
I heard you say that it matters to you
the group that you're going to be
working with so how did you know with
the manson family vacation this was the
right group for you the right sort of
film family well Josh Logan told me it
was and Josh Logan is one of the
producers on this film and I had worked
with him on a film that we shot in
Thailand I don't know 10 15 years ago
and he we kind of stayed in touch and he
he told me about Jay Duplass and jay
davis and and he said these people are
experienced they can do what they say
they're going to do and their first rate
and so that was step one and they came
well recommended and they delivered on
what was promised also so in the future
or four prior projects how would you
know as well that that you felt it was
the right vibe was it a gut feeling when
there was another production that wanted
you to be a part of it was there just
something that told you yes do this no
don't the material if once i was told
that these guys know how to make a film
then i looked at the material carefully
and i thought wow this material is the
potential to be multi-layered story
that's amusing and heartfelt and dynamic
in many ways and makes you think and so
it was very rich in that way and and
tobin when he read the script was very
focused on the whole you know he came
back with notes that weren't just about
his character but were about the story
itself the brothers relationship and I
was like what you know I really want to
work with this guy who cares about you
know the entire movie
right I want to get more into the improv
in just a moment cuz I think there were
some parts but for Jay I felt that I
really related to Conrad's character and
I'm wondering for your various
screenings in festival screenings maybe
have others come up to you and said i am
conrad or my brother or sister is Conrad
and I relate to this story um I I've had
yeah i mean i've had people who very
strongly relate to Conrad I feel like it
kind of you know certain people kind of
gravitate more towards Nick and certain
gravitate more toward Conrad and for me
it's you know I don't have a brother I'm
an only child so for me these two
characters are kind of sides of my
personality so I mean that's how I kind
of related to it as I was writing it
whereas for Jay and lynus each of them
you know they have brothers and had
sibling relationships so they approached
it that way for me it was you know it
was two sides of myself in a way
interesting well you had a successful
Kickstarter campaign in 2013 and I just
want to read something from the
description and ask you why you feel the
theme is important so it's about a theme
of people who feel lost in society and
their family and in their job why does
that interest you I feel like both the
characters are lost in their own ways
and they both kind of have to reckon
with their pasts I mean that's what the
movie to me is about is each of them
reckoning with their pasts in there
in their own ways okay hello it now I
believe you gave the actors a lot of
freedom in some sense to improvise their
lines can you talk about how that was an
either for either of you Tobin just
being you know as your character
Blackbird did you feel you know what Jay
can I say this rather than that was it a
sort of a set where you just felt that
freedom or how closely did you want the
actress to follow the lines I mean with
jay and Lunas it was clear to me early
on that that I that they should be able
to go off script to you know to say that
they I did I didn't want to focus on the
lines I focused on the beats of the
scene but it was best for them to kind
of say things in their own words and you
know once we got the scene in the can
then we could explore a little more
because they had you know their special
kind of rapport together yeah it worked
and and yeah I mean it sort of depended
on how somebody wanted to work yeah I
don't any with Tobin I feel like we
improved a bit but we stuck a little
more closely to the script oh yeah yeah
so there was a we had an early on
discussion about some remarks that
Blackbird made about Charlie and we made
some adjustments when it came to those
remarks except for that I stuck pretty
much to what was what was scripted kind
of worked around the boys and you know
what they were doing at the moment yeah
how does that feel for you when you are
given freedom with lines is it is it is
it freeing is it a little bit terrifying
or it depends on the project it's an
interesting question because I've had
both experiences i I really i mean most
of the projects that I've worked on
are scripted and one if the script is
well written and well and ready then it
doesn't need you to be improvising and
most of the directors that I worked with
whether it's wolfgang petersen or or
Sydney they they don't want you
improvising the script is is crafted in
a certain kind of way and that's the way
they want it but this is a different
situation so sometimes it's marvelous
and sometimes it seems really chaotic so
I have both feelings about it you do do
you still take acting classes even after
all these these performances in my head
in your head oh yeah no I work all the
time on on back story all the time so I
know what it is I'm talking about
because a line can mean many different
things and I need to know specifically
what i mean by what I say interesting J
for you I believe you work full-time at
a post-production house mm-hmm and so
how are you balancing doing this screen
writing as I'm imagine you're dealing
with a full plate and I think you you
were runner-up in the nickel fellowship
like screenplay competition so how are
you how are you managing all this um I
was lucky enough that you know my work
kind of let me take a sabbatical to
shoot the movie yes and here yeah thanks
guys yeah thank you for ever you are but
yeah thnkx HR sorry but yeah and yeah
I've just been working on things you
know as I have the time you know it's a
balancing act do you attack the day
writing pages or do you find yourself
procrastinating when I'm when I'm
writing something I
to do it the first thing okay now in the
morning and no I tend to really attack
it when I'm when I when I'm in the swing
of it so you're you're you're sort of
your own taskmaster because i know
that's that's half the battle so many
people come to LA they work that job and
everything creative starts to fall by
the wayside ya know I yeah i'm a self
motivator yeah and there's no one else
it's gonna be it you know is going to be
doing it for me so yeah what do you
think that comes from um I don't know
the compulsion to work and succeed
genetic I'm not sure this question is
for either of you any advice for the
conrads of the world the ones that are
slightly different maybe they're not
embraced by society the workplace their
families they're not bad people but
they're just slightly different and
maybe they're not on the level of the
Knicks in terms of career and social
status yeah I would only say that there
what's interesting about this film is
that that the conrads of the world can
learn something from the Knicks of the
world and the Knicks as you see in this
film learn something from the conrads we
get stuck in our own perceptions and way
of looking at things and and we need to
be open we're all connected and one of
the wonderful things about this film is
that it's so much about finding the
truth and
its leaves you're thinking well said I
can't say anything better than that